on Fox for some reason this conversation
about Michigan Michigan State comes up
during the game and John used the same
line again about Michigan people running
and hiding and I was just honestly
sitting now I know it's not about me
certainly not on Fox you're about to
make it about you
astral game Rich Eisen believe which
isin loves rich I mean John Smoltz back
here under Rich Eisen show Jonah I mean
kind of what gives is my first question
for you from Houston either just
question might circular first question
that you know it was for some family
members that immediately texted me okay
after that got on the air and it did it
did serve its purpose I still haven't
gotten a call back from jay Feely laugh
okay I've left a couple messages making
sure it's not affected his work you know
the work he's got to do for the NFL so
I'm a little concerned there but though
you you jump right to the top I mean
just imagine that is first-class as it
gets and stamping stand up stand up to
it okay I'm shocked by some of the other
people now look you know I was just
sitting there I'm like is he gonna say
something of course you didn't say
anything I texted Joe right at the
moment and I got a bit moji back saying
fake news that's what he said and I'm
like come on now Joe first of all that's
when I learned how to joke bit mo geez
you know John what's happening down
there in Houston today brother tell me
what do you expect to happen in Game six
tonight John well you know obviously
this series has turned on a dime and it
turned I think sometimes you look for a
moment you look for an at-bat and not to
put it on will Harris but Judge got
going on a 3-2 fastball in a homer he
hasn't been the same since he's been and
that was the key for the for the Yankees
it almost like started their engines and
they haven't looked back
for obviously with a four nothing lead
is a tough loss mentally to deal with
and it carried over into the next star I
believe and it's hard to just kind of
detach that as a player it's in the back
of your mind but the Yankees have been
good at home offensively they've been
great and I think what what this series
will come down to you know it's always
in series in game adjustments but I
think that if the sum of the left-handed
hitters for the for the Astros don't get
going they need somebody to click a
switch like Judge did and then it's
going to be a Game seven
no doubt in my mind just the way this
game a series has been going and the way
each team has played at home so Justin
Verlander attacked him with a lot of
fast balls first time through I'll be
interested to see if that changes or if
he stays with that or if the Yankees get
a little more aggressive because they're
up there a passive hitting team what I
mean by that is they like to work the
count but Justin Verlander had Oh two
one two and just about everybody he
wanted to and that gave him the
successful game that he had game - so
who's those lefties you're looking at
Rennick McCann Beltran from the
switch-hitting spot those are the guys
and if so which one things got the
credit for you know for sure Redick he
had such a great year and he's in the
top of the lineup with Springer and
Radek have not been able to do much
combine that they'd only have like one
hit in the series Heretic doesn't have a
hit yet so a little bit of pressing
going on but I tell you a hit or double
or just something to get on in front of
Carlos and of course Altuve would really
help I mean the crowds going to be crazy
and you know the motion of Verlander is
gonna be locked in it just comes down to
the Houston offense was the best in
baseball has gone gone dormant I mean
it's like a 147 167 team batting average
and never saw that coming a credit the
gameplan of the Yankees and Larry
Rothschild their pitching staff has been
unbelievable so what should we look for
in the first couple of innings tonight
John based on what you said if the
Yankees start swinging at first pitches
that's the adjustment being made
or Verlander starts going off speed and
the sum of the first offerings that he
makes to the Yankees I mean what what
should we be looking at to see if game
six is he a repeat of Game two
yeah I love the cat-and-mouse chess game
you know people ask well I'm a pitcher
successful should he change first and I
say no but the one that bat that will
set the tone is in the first inning with
judge because he swing it and see in the
fall a lot better and Verlander pitched
up tough man and kind of throw them into
that continual funk and it's at some
point the ability to hit a fastball for
the Yankees is really good but the
ability to trust the fastball you see
how everybody gets scared against the
Yankees oh well maybe not scared that's
the wrong word the formula for success
spin the baseball keep spinning the
baseball and don't throw any basketball
so I would say if I'm guessing if I'm
the incus and I got a game to play with
I would be untraditionally more
aggressive early against a Verlander who
basically said here's my fastball good
luck outer corner not much you can do
with it so I would look for that I would
be intrigued to see if they come out
maybe not Gardner because he's kind of
that pesky follow the ball off that guy
and wait for a pitch he wants but I
would look pretty aggressive maybe a
little more aggressive approach out of
the ink John Smoltz Fox Sports gonna
call the World Series he'll be here in
Los Angeles on Tuesday and Chavez's
Ravine Corey Seager expected to be back
in the lineup and the Dodgers will have
everything lined up the way they want it
pitching wise because of the fact that
they wrap things up last night who do
you think the Dodgers would like to see
playing against them and Chavez Ravine
hard hearts John well III think it's
similar to to what happened when the
question was asked when they finished
Arizona quick who would they rather see
the penis the most banged up that had to
use most players and that was the cup
they had to get through Game five series
of the Nationals and exhausted so many
of their weapons that they didn't have a
lot of weapons moving forward so you
know from it from a standpoint of what
the Dodgers would want I think games
seven goes 12 innings and let's get it
however however however they want at
that point I think this this has such
intrigue of course the storylines are
credible with the Yankees Dodgers
historical matchups in the past but what
the at least before this series start of
what the Astros could do the pitching
staffs was pretty pretty unreal
it's just not happened this series so
from a from a bullpen matchup the
Yankees equal the Dodgers from a bullpen
matchup the Astros do not and from a
starter matchup of course the Dodgers
are going to be in the best position
they can be with arrested arm so they
did a nice job taking care of business
as early as possible that's long answer
I don't think it matters in this leg and
before I let you go were you surprised
with the letting go of Dusty Baker and
the entire staff there in Washington as
was announced about a couple hours ago
John yeah I'm very surprised I think but
there's situations that are more
difficult to walk into than the next job
and what he did what does he did with
the personalities just all the things
that come with Washington I thought I
did a fantastic job and for whatever
reason they haven't been able to win a
series and move on and their windows
getting a little shorter with the guys
that are left so I am surprised honestly
I thought he did a great job manage that
ballclub for honored 62 games and you
know let's face it I mean it would have
been nice to have Harper a little bit
more from healthier than what he was it
was a miracle that he came back and did
what he did and their offense just kind
of did not show up but the way that it
again the way that the season provided
and then in what based on what we saw on
the NLCS as well would you be up for
changing the so called Buster Posey rule
based on what we saw in the NLCS that
Joe Maddon went crazy about and that was
on the same night as Justin Verlander
threw that old school old school
throwback moment we're all living about
love and how baseball still as adults
cool mentality and then that night
player safety and instant replay
converged in a way that was such a new
millennium that's difficult to wrap your
arms around would you be up for changing
that in the offseason John yeah if
nothing else just some more clarity I
don't think people understand it the
players don't I think there's so much
that I saw a play right afterwards that
Katara complete contreras completely
blocked a plate once he was able to get
the ball and shift over like I don't
understand that that part I don't
understand and the runner is that more
of a harm now than the catcher is I
don't think you should ever go out of
your way to hit the catcher I think if
the catcher gives you no place to go you
should be able to run him home but I
understand the sport that we're in and a
lot of sports for is an over reaction
for the major injuries that's what I get
and I and I get all that honestly if
it's you know if there was a better way
to not have a home plate but throw a
pop-up base you know it would be easier
to slide into a base at home than it
would a home plate because that's the
biggest problem is you can't get your
foot down slide in feet first on a plate
that's flat but if there's a bag there
it's much easier that's why a lot of
guys go in headfirst they're going way
wide try to reach back so the base
runner is that way more risk today then
the hitter is and speaking of rule
changes if I may add please the NFL
needs to make a rule change I'm still
bitter about how the felt of Alliance
lost to the Falcon if that 10-second run
off and it happened again last night
David did it all but the and the Raiders
had what we thought was only one play
left who knew there were two more after
that I'm with you John but I mean
instant replay in the same way that I
thought of that play when Lobaton got
picked off a first just that once or
what happened with Safari and Jane
congest that last week against the
Patriots where the ball was not in his
possession just at the second that he
over that he went over the line of
scrimmage once you open the the world to
instant replay it's tough to put it back
it just really is well what I don't
understand is it's not you know it's
called a
down right and so the players if it
weren't caught a touchdown they'd race
right up to the line
they'd spike the ball and they'd have
all the time they want but because of
anyways I mean the Lions lost a game
they shouldn't of it there's a 10-second
run off I just don't like it I don't
like it that's John Smoltz Lions fan and
also outstanding analysts with Joe Buck
for a game that I'm fired up for thanks
for calling in John all right my
pleasure
for more Rich Eisen show tune to
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Rich Eisen show app